president of yougov peter great to see
you thanks for joining me good morning
um i i guess the first
question is whether
partygate itself is still a damaging
issue for the prime minister and the
conservatives uh across the country for
voters versus of course the focus that
has been on what it meant for how uh the
members of the mp the conservative mps
were thinking about their leader
yeah if you look at the
polling will prince boris johnson uh is
now plainly a liability um his rating as
prime minister is pretty catastrophic
you have to go back to people like john
major
in the mid 90s or gordon brown about 15
years ago to get
prime ministers in equivalent trouble
with the public
and there are two things worth
remembering about john mage and gordon
brown
both were thrown out by the electorate
but neither was thrown out by their own
party in both cases there was a
attempt to maneuver against him by
people around him um but john major and
gordon brown survived so if you take
that historic precedent we shouldn't be
terribly surprised if boris johnson
terrible though his public ratings are
survives within the conservative party
and and talk us through the sort of
broad polls national polls we're seeing
also the polls for those upcoming uh
by-elections that i i mentioned and the
significance of those local election
results uh clearly they weren't good for
the conservatives but is it wrong to try
and extrapolate too much from them right
the local elections um
wilfred they showed labor broadly over
the country as a whole narrowly but only
narrowly ahead of the conservatives now
all history of mid-term
local elections says that governments
recover as the following election
approaches so history repeats itself and
it's one of the reasons why boris
johnson i think is feeling a bit chipper
at the moment if history repeats itself
the conservatives could well come back
and win the next election the question
really is is this mid-term
different you know we've got the cost of
living crisis we've got predictions of
the economy stalling over the next
couple of years as the next election
approaches so the hope for the
conservatives is that history repeats
itself the fear is that this time
it's different and you know i wouldn't
put too much money either way
let's touch on on the significance of
the cost of living crisis clearly the
next general election could be more than
two years away and so much can happen
between
now and then but in a hypothetical
situation where the economy worsens
perhaps is bad enough to take us into
recession and the
economy is still struggling by the time
of the next general election what does
history tell us about uh the scale to
which an incumbent government gets
punished for that
it can get
punished wilfred the the phrase that
comes to my mind is not from britain but
when ronald reagan stood for president
in the states in 1980 against the
incumbent jimmy carter and ronald
reagan's killer question to the public
was
do you feel better off than you were
four years ago when carter became
president
and the american public said no and they
elected reagan and throughout carter so
i think it's quite possible this is why
this midterm could be different but in
the next election uh the fact that we've
had um
the inflation running ahead of incomes
but after remember after what will then
be 15 years
of austerity and living standards which
have not moved forward so i think a lot
of people will feel hard done by
it may not be infected i would say it
isn't on the whole this government
support the short-term problem which
comes from abroad but you know
governments take credit
for things where they're lucky and they
um get blamed when they're unlucky and
this government to the moment in terms
of cost of living is unlucky and they
will be blamed
maybe uh kierstama should take note of
that uh that campaign slogan from from
ronald reagan um that you just mentioned
on the note of kierstama
which of the two parties would benefit
more from a leadership
change at the moment there's lots of
factors that play as to how that could
materialize but is he doing a good job
well to answer the first part of your
question wilfred it's very hard to say
because it's not clear in either case
who would succeed if you were having
this discussion in january about boris
johnson you say boris johnson
went tomorrow richie sunak i would
become prime minister and all the polls
at that point show that rishi sunak was
a vote winner that's no longer the case
for reasons we we don't need to go into
that they're pretty clear both in terms
of his personal and family circumstances
and what's happening to the
british economy um so it's not at all
clear
who if anybody would do better than
boris johnson even though he's a
liability and it's one reason why i
think a lot of tory mps at the moment
are reluctant to move against him but on
the labor side again
if kia stammer was forced to carry out
his promise to uh quits if he gets uh
fines by the durham police over beer
gate or whatever you call it cormogate
um
who would take over um angela probably
not because she was also at that
event and might also get fined so she's
out of it then you look at um yvette's
cooper some people are talking about
andy burnham um
um we're streeting
none of them um
it is
there's no clarity from the polling on
any of them that they would do a lot
better than clear stamina so we
were walking into the unknown in both
parties
and then just finally peter the two
upcoming by-elections does the
conservative party hold on
um i think the the political market has
written them off they expect the
conservatives to lose weight fields to
labor and tibetan to the liberal
democrats bizarrely even if there are
big swings and the conservatives hold on
to even one of them
it will be better than expectations and
it's one of those cases where
expectations matter as much as the
results um
if labor when wakefield's big if the
liberal democrats win timberton big
that will be a problem for boris johnson
whether it be enough to get rid of him
um i don't know but the facts that um
that we're talking as if it's expected
the conservatives will lose doesn't
underline uh the the trouble the
conservatives are in whether whether
they keep boris johnson or not